Pergunta que eu recebi. Tomo vitamina D,
10.000 unidades por dia por via
sublingual, mais 15 minutos de sol todos
os dias e a minha vitamina D no sangue
não passa de 30. Por quê? Olha só essa
situação que eu vejo com frequência no
custódio e que deixa muita gente cabelo
em pé. Imagina só, você está tomando
10.000 imunidade, vitamina Dodo santo
dia ainda pega aqueles 15 minutinhos de
sol que todo mundo fala que é sagrado. E
quando vai ver o exame do sangue, 30 ng
por milro. É de ficar maluco, né? Parece
que a vitamina D está brincando esconde
esconde no seu corpo. Mas calma que eu
vou explicar direitinho porque isso
acontece e garanto que no final você vai
entender que o seu corpo não está de
fato te sabotando. Sabe aquela história
de que não adianta só colocar gasolina
no carro se o motor está com problema?
Pois é, com a vitamina D é a mesma
coisa. Muitas vezes não adianta você
tomar 10.000 unidade de vitamina D
sublingual se o seu corpo não consegue
processá-la direito. E olha que
interessante, estudos recentes de 2024,
2025 mostram que até 40% da população
tem polimorfismos genéticos no receptor
de vitamina D, o famoso VDR. É como se
você tivesse a fechadura, mas a chave
não encaixa direito. O GNVDR pode ter
variações que fazem com que a vitamina D
não se ligue adequadamente aos
receptores celulares. É tipo tentar
abrir a porta de casa com uma chave meio
torta. Às vezes funciona, mas precisa de
muito mais esforço. E tem mais coisa
nessa história toda. A vitamina D é uma
patricinha, viu? Ela precisa de um monte
de cofatores para funcionar direito. O
magnésio, por exemplo, é fundamental
para converter a vitamina D na sua forma
ativa, sem magnésio suficiente. Você
pode tomar vitamina D em doses
supostamente boas e ela pode ficar
paradinha sem fazer nada. É como ter um
carro de Fórmula 1 sem o piloto. E não é
só o magnésio, não. A vitamina K2 também
entra nessa dança. Ela ajuda a
direcionar o cálcio pros lugares certos,
trabalhando em parceria com a vitamina
D. Quando falta K2, a vitamina D fica
meio perdida, sem saber direito o que
fazer com o cálcio que ela ajudou a
absorver. Agora vem uma parte que muita
gente nem imagina. O seu intestino pode
estar sabotando todo o processo. A
disbiose intestinal, que é quando as
bactérias ruins ganham das boas no seu
intestino, prejudica demais a absorção
de vitamina D. É como se você tivesse um
porteiro mal morado que não deixa
ninguém entrar. As bactérias benéficas,
especialmente as bifidobactérias,
são essenciais para absorção de
vitaminas liposolúveis como a D. Quando
elas estão em falta e as bactérias
patogênicas tomam conta, a absorção vai
pro espaço. E pior, a disbiose ainda
causa inflamação intestinal, aumenta a
permeabilidade do intestino, aquela
história do intestino hiper permeável
que todo mundo fala. Isso prejudica
ainda mais a absorção não só da vitamina
D, mas de todos os nutrientes
importantes. Tem gente que tem o que
chamamos de resistência à vitamina D. É
parecido com a resistência à insulina no
diabetes, sabe? Então, o corpo produz ou
recebe a substância, mas as células meio
que ignoram ela. Isso pode acontecer por
várias razões, seja obesidade, porque a
vitamina D fica presa no tecido adiposo,
tecido gorduroso, problemas no fígado
que onde acontece a primeira
hidroxilação da vitamina ou problemas
renais onde ocorre a segunda
hidroxilação para formar o calcetriol, a
forma superativa da vitamina D. Alguns
medicamentos também atrapalham tudo,
seja anticonvulsivantes, corticoides e
até alguns remédios para colesterol
podem interferir no metabolismo da
vitamina D. E tem um detalhe importante
sobre a via sublingual que você está
utilizando. Apesar de ser uma boa
estratégia para evitar o intestino em
caso de má absorção, ela tem as suas
limitações. A vitamina D ela é
lipossolúvel, então ela precisa de
gordura para ser absorvida
adequadamente. Então a absorção
sublingual pode não ser tão eficiente
quanto parece, especialmente se não
houver um veículo oleoso adequado. Além
disso, mesmo entrando pela via
sublingual, ela ainda precisa passar
pelo fígado e pelos ins para ser
ativada. E se esses órgãos não estão
funcionando bem, a conversão fica
prejudicada. Então, a questão da
exposição solar também tem os seus
porens. 15 minutos podem não ser
suficientes, dependendo de vários
fatores. A latitude, onde você mora, a
época do ano, a cor da sua pele, a
idade, o uso de protetor solar, a
poluição do ar e até o horário que você
pega sol. Aqui no Brasil, mesmo com todo
esse sol maravilhoso, estudos mostram
que grande parte da população tem
deficiência de vitamina D. É um paradoxo
tropical. A pele mais velha, ela produz
menos vitamina D e aos 70 anos a
produção pode ser 25%
menor do que era aos 20. E se você mora
em cidade grande com muita poluição, os
raios ultravioleta B, que são
necessários para a síntese de vitamina
D, nem chegam direito na sua pele. Olha
que coisa interessante que as novas
diretrizes de 2024 da Indrent Society
trouxeram. Eles nem estabelecem mais o
valor ideal único para todo mundo. E
pela visão da medicina funcional, nós
queremos deixar a vitamina D no sangue
entre 40 e 70, apesar de que valores
menores teoricamente podem ser
suficiente para várias pessoas. Então,
meu amigo, minha amiga, se você está
nessa situação de tomar vitamina D e vê
que ela não sobe, o negócio é investigar
mais a fundo. Primeiro, vale a pena
checar se você não tem polimorfismos no
GNV VDR. Hoje em dia tem exame genético
para isso. Segundo, verificar os seus
níveis de magnésio, não só no sangue,
mas o magnésio intracelular, que é o que
realmente importa. Terceiro, cuidar do
seu intestino, fazer um trabalho de
modulação intestinal com probióticos,
prebióticos, talvez até investigar se
tem sim intestino hiperpermeável ou
alguma intolerância alimentar causando
inflamação. E tem mais, verificar a
função hepática e renal, ver se não está
usando medicamentos que interferem,
avaliar a composição corporal, porque o
excesso de gordura pode sequestrar a
vitamina D e até considerar usar formas
diferentes dessa vitamina. No seu caso,
eu recomendaria você passar paraa
vitamina D. oral mesmo, tomar junto com
gorduras saudáveis, como é o caso do
ômega-3, e dobrar a dose
temporariamente, fazendo acompanhamento
médico. A medicina funcional olha para
esse quebra-cabeça todo e tenta montar
as peças. Não é só jogar a vitamina D
para dentro, guela baixo e torcer para
subir. É entender porque o seu corpo
específico com sua genética única, seu
intestino particular, seu estilo de vida
individual não está conseguindo
aproveitar essa vitamina. É um trabalho
de detetive mesmo, mas quando a gente
descobre o que está travando o processo
e consegue corrigir, aí sim os níveis
sobem. E mais importante, você sente a
diferença, que é o caso mais energia,
imunidade melhor, humor mais estável e
ossos mais fortes. Então não desanime. O
seu corpo não está contra você. Ele só
precisa de uma ajudinha extra para fazer
a vitamina D trabalhar direito. É
questão de encontrar qual é o seu calcar
de aquiles nessa história toda, que pode
ser genético, pode ser intestinal, pode
ser falta de cofatores, pode ser um
pouquinho de cada coisa. Então, o
importante é não desistir e investigar
de maneira correta, porque a vitamina D
baixa a longo prazo, não é brincadeira.
Ela pode afetar os seus ossos, o seu
humor, a sua imunidade, o seu
metabolismo. Ela afeta tudo, afeta
muitos genes. Mas com a abordagem certa,
personalizada pro seu caso, dá para
resolver sim. É só não querer aplicar a
receita de bolo em um processo que é
totalmente individual. M.